[Music]
growing up i desperately wanted to feel
a sense of connection and belonging
as an asian american raised in new canon
connecticut there were very few people
of color and even fewer who looked like
me
and i didn't need to look myself in the
mirror to see that i was different
instead my classmates reminded me of it
every single day
slant their eyes at me in the hallway
instead of saying hello they'd greet me
by saying konichiwa
and they'd call me nicknames like jackie
chan
now in most cases these actions were
delivered as jokes rather than
ill-spirited racism
but regardless the message was clear
i didn't fit in
at first i was frustrated and confused
i collected pokemon cards just like
everyone else i watched spongebob just
like everyone else
i thought i was american just like
everyone else
eventually frustration and confusion
turned into darker feelings of
loneliness and self-doubt
i'm not good enough i told myself
i'm not white enough
i don't fit in
to combat these insecurities i began to
shun my asian-ness
i ignored my chinese teacher
i refused to eat sushi or used
chopsticks
i was even more excited to celebrate st
patrick's day than chinese new year
kinda crazy
but at the end of the day i still looked
asian
and so
the jokes still came
humans have two basic but powerful
psychological needs
the first is to fit in
the second is to stand out
we all want to feel a sense of belonging
and yet we all also want to feel special
a study conducted in 2019 found that
over 60 percent of americans report
feeling lonely
another survey found that 8 in 10
millennials believe
they aren't good enough
i felt disheartened hearing these
statistics
but they also reminded me that i am not
alone in feeling alone
when my grandfather who he called yaya
immigrated from china in 1951 he arrived
in the u.s with nothing and with no one
he told my dad that he often felt hungry
homesick
and alone
the language barrier made it nearly
impossible for him to connect
with other americans
but
while he was pursuing his masters at the
university of michigan he began to
develop an interest in american sports
he then moved to new york city where
that interest evolved into a lifelong
passion for several new york sports
teams
as a kid i remember him sporting a gray
new york giants crew neck sweatshirt
anytime he came to visit us
it took me several years to fully grasp
the importance of yaya's love for sports
but i now see how becoming a sports fan
helped him fit in
in 2004 my grandparents moved in with us
and for the next seven years
yaya didn't miss a single michigan
football game
he watched every single new york giants
yankees rangers and knicks game
why you might ask
because they reminded him of the
happiest moments of his life
the times when he felt like an insider
rather than an outsider
sports was a common bond that helped him
to transcend differences and connect
with his classmates colleagues and
grandchildren
today i want to propose a new solution
for conquering feelings of loneliness
and self-doubt
i want everyone here to consider sports
as a cure for the fear of disconnection
when we feel alone what we need most is
connection with others
in sports of a unique superpower that
brings people together regardless of
background
sports turn outsiders
into insiders
take for example how becoming a sports
fan instantly connects you with a
community
when we feel invested in a sport or team
or an athlete
we automatically feel a sense of
camaraderie with others with similar
affinities
sports psychologist dr daniel wan has
conducted multiple studies that have
found statistically significant
correlations between sports team
identification and several measures of
mental health
including self-esteem and life
satisfaction
and sports are accessible to anyone
there are no prerequisites no membership
fees and no application processes
sports also gave us a platform to build
deeper relationships
research conducted by professor brian
uzi at the kellogg school of management
found that the secret to building deep
relationships is shared experiences
and while there are many different types
of shared experiences sports are unique
in their inherent combination of
socialness
levity and authenticity
consider the fact that 95 of the top 100
most watched tv programs last year were
sports telecasts
or consider the fact that there are
thousands of sports bars around the
world
but have yet to come across any movie
bars or politics bars
has anyone here ever been to a weather
bar
yeah me neither
sports are built-in social events
that allow us to build and grow human
connection
in may 2012 i attended a college
lacrosse game that changed my life
forever
on that day i met an incredible girl
named amy
now on the surface amy and i had very
little in common
amy was a blond-haired blue-eyed
politics and philosophy major from rural
virginia
not how i'd describe myself
but on that day sports allowed us to
focus on the things we shared rather
than our differences
we shared our first meal together
a warm sugar-coated funnel cake from the
concession stand
and we cheered on our classmates from
the bleachers together
10 years later
and i can't wait to marry amy this fall
yet without sports we may have never
realized the potential for a fulfilling
lifelong relationship
and finally
sports enable us to embrace our
differences
consider serena williams who dove head
first into a sport lawn associated with
money and privilege
serena has gone on to win 23 grand slam
singles titles and is the only american
male or female to have won more than 20
majors
serena has become one of the greatest
athletes of all time
in a recent interview serena shared
i wouldn't be who i am
i wouldn't be as strong as i am
i wouldn't have been able to be as
amazing as i've been so far in my career
i wouldn't be me
if i wasn't black
being asian in america is hard
being a minority in america is hard
you can't help but think about the
things that make you different
every single
day
but as sports have helped me to feel
more connected to the world
i've been able to reframe those
differences
i wouldn't have had the same life
experiences if i wasn't asian
i wouldn't have the same view of the
world if i wasn't asian
i wouldn't be standing here today if i
wasn't asian
if i wasn't asian i wouldn't be me
when sports help me to fit in
being asian empowers me to stand out
yiya spent 60 years in america before
passing in 2011 after a 10-year battle
with parkinson's disease
but his love for sports lives deep in
the hearts of my dad
my three younger brothers and myself
he taught us a universal language the
language of sports
that has helped us to build bridges to
our american side of being asian
american
i'm 16 years old playing running back
for my high school's varsity football
team
as i jog out of the locker room and onto
the field i no longer see slanted eyes
no one says kunichiwa
no one calls me jackie chan
instead i'm greeted with high fives and
chest bumps
and as i join my teammates in the huddle
on the field the quarterback jimmy
simply turns to me
nods and says
let's go brother
embracing sports is the single most
important thing i've done for myself
it's been my cheat code for fostering
connection and combating loneliness
here at the gsb
i have built valuable friendships on the
soccer field at maples pavilion
and at old pro the sports bar downtown
by giving me a home where i fit in
sports have given me the courage
to embrace my differences
and appreciate how special it is to be
asian american
i'm asian and i'm american
i fit in
and i stand out
so the next time you feel alone or like
you're not good enough
find a sport or a team or an athlete
that interests you
it could be one of stanford's 36 varsity
sports teams
or could be your daughter's little
league team
and then go watch a game
you never know
who you might meet
[Applause]
[Music]